focus à présent sur une pratique encore
parfois un peu tabou celle du don du
corps à la science à tour
220 personnes en moyenne donnent leurs
corps chaque année un chiffre en baisse
qui trouve son explication dans le
scandale qui éclate fin 2019 à
l'université de médecine de paris
descartes où l'on découvre des corps
conservé dans des conditions indécentes
donner son corps à la science est
pourtant très utile dans certains
apprentissages en médecine et recherche
scientifique
samuel coule donc les corps sont sur ses
tables en principe on met la tête ici
ils sont sur le dos ou alors après sur
le ventre en fonction de la zone
atomique explorer baptiste aimerait
devenir chirurgien pour lui les cours
d'anatomie sont indispensables entre les
livres et la réalité il ya quand même
une marge qui est assez importante
on apprend beaucoup de choses par le
toucher et c'est une partie qu'on n'a
pas autrement
ce sont des princes du quai richomme qui
permettent aussi d'enlever les petits
morceaux d'os le laboratoire est utilisé
en formation initiale dès la deuxième
année de médecine
c'est ici par exemple que l'on peut
apprendre à faire des points de suture
une des grandes règles actuellement fait
de ne pas faire un geste sur le patient
avant d'avoir fait sur sur autre chose
autre chose ça peut être un mannequin
mais le meilleur mannequin ça reste
encore le corps humain pour que civils
et à l'atome il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
grand chose d'autre pour l'instant les
dons servent aussi à la recherche et à
la formation continue pour des médecins
des infirmiers de bloc opératoire ou
même des kinésithérapeutes les corps
sont conservés en chambre froide les
durées varient
l'idée tirer parti du don au maximum
mais les engagements sont en baisse une
inquiétude pour les futurs étudiants
thierry choisi lui de donner son corps
en 1986 après avoir accompagné son père
jusqu'au bout dans une maladie
douloureuse
quelques années plus tard des
chirurgiens lui sauve la vie au prix de
sa jambe
des chirurgiens qui ont fait un boulot
fantastique mais qui n'aurait peut-être
pas pu le faire s'il n'avait pas eu
justement accès à des cours d'anatomie à
des possibilités d'avoir accès à des
corps pour pouvoir répéter des
interventions
et ça c'est important en fin de compte
donner mon corps c'est une mort qui sert
pour la vie voilà une soixantaine de
corps sont passées aux laboratoires
depuis le début de l'année ils sont
ensuite incinéré au crématorium desvres
une cérémonie a alors lieu pour la
famille